y la situación sigue estando bajo
investigación la policía metropolitana
estará asumiendo el liderazgo en esta
sigue proveyendo personal y recursos
tiene situación a la alredor del
capitolio y está respondiendo a las
solicitudes de asistencia pues ya hay
muchos acuerdos en curso como ha
escuchado el alcalde se ha puesto un
toque que a partir de las seis de la
tarde estar en efecto a partir de a seis
de la mañana de mañana 7 de enero
estamos recomendando todos a todos que
no estén involucrados en actividades que
salgan de las calles y se adhieran a la
al toque que así se les ve violando el
toque de queda a la gente la policía
deberá tomar acción de nuevo quiero
reiterar y dejar bastante claro por
favor cumplen el toque de queda que el
alcalde ha establecido o serán sujetos
al arresto finalmente sé que muchos
están familiarizados con el departamento
metropolitano de policía entienden que
no hay una mejor agencia en el país para
manejar eventos de este tipo sucede
ocasionalmente en esa ciudad ahora los
eventos de hoy no representan las
protestas pacíficas lo que presenciamos
hoy fue motín ilegal la gente que llega
a la ciudad que entra en comportamientos
ilegales será responsabilizada podemos
tomar preguntas después de la secretaria
después de que sectario puede hablar
muchas gracias alcalde balls el jefe
contigo al revés de la serie de la tarde
movilizamos a la guardia nacional de
washington una fuerza completa de 100
por ciento fueron llevados a la armería
para respaldar a la policía
metropolitana y reestablecer la
seguridad en los confines del capitolio
también estaremos trabajando con otras
entidades de fuerza federal
para tener respaldo adicional a medida
que se sigue planeando la respuesta y
como manejamos esta operación muchas
gracias
habrán
así a cambio incluyente
podría hablar sobre la confusión que
acerca del despliegue de la guardia
nacional se dijo originalmente que se
había negado a permitir estos guardias
de reforzar la seguridad del capitolio
puede aclarar qué fue lo que sucedió no
estoy seguro de qué declaración se
refiere pero déjenme ser clara yo o
solicite la asistencia de la guardia
creo que hace dos o tres días
para respaldar la operación del gobierno
de washington la presión del tráfico de
la policía metropolitana también y esa
petición fue aprobada por el sectario el
ejército adicionalmente como entiendo y
le pedirá al secretario que hable eso
directamente el capitolio de la policía
el departamento policía del capitolio
estadounidense pidió apoyo adicional hoy
entonces quiero dejarles bancario hola
soy raya mccarthy cuando estuvimos
trabajando por esas solicitudes
adicionales
esta petición adicional de parte de la
policía del capitolio para que nosotros
realmente pudiéramos entender los
detalles detrás de esa petición y cómo
poder respaldar su operación hubo muchas
preguntas hubo un poco de confusión pero
a medida que trabajamos pudimos lograr
la coordinación media hora después para
movilizar a toda la guardia nacional ha
sido una situación increíblemente fluida
pero tengo que pasar por el secretario
de defensa finalmente para lograr la
aprobación final para movilizar el
personal así como para conducir
operaciones en
cooperación y coordinación con nuestras
autoridades locales
w
ali de w y envío
el toque de queda de la ciudad puede
aplicar a varias propiedades el toque de
que aplica en toda la ciudad es su
pregunta es si hay gente que está en la
zona del capitolio están sujetas a la
capital a la al toque que deben seguir
las leyes de la policía en los
territorios se les pedirá que evacua en
el capitolio
la escuela
quien lo hará la misma policía